L ARMIA DRAWS
A PENALTY MIDDLE
OF A.M.
AND DELAYS THE PUCK AUND OPPORTY
AND COLE CAULFIELD JUST PEELED
IT.
HAD NET BYELD.
A COUPLE OF CHANCES FOR
CAULFIELD ON THAT
ONE.
ONE TIME.
GLOVE STOP ON A.M.
DON'T OFTEN SEE ARMIA WITH TRAT.
WE COULD HEAR THAT FROM UP
HERE.
THE VEL GOOD LOOK.
ANDD
REBOUND.
PITLICK BACK HAND TRY.OUTUBE.COM
HE MANAGES THE GAME.
I THINK H STICK OF CHARA WENT
WIDE.
AS IL MIDDLE OF THE
ICE.
DVORAK GREATAT
PAGEAU WRIST SHOT.CE.
ARMIA LOOKING FOR IT AND FINALLY
SOCKS ON.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE GAME
WEARING BUT TO THE ARENA.
ON THE
>> BOUNCING PUCK.
ARMIA GETS IT.
STOPPEDREY
PRICE.
THROWS IT BACK.RS LEAD 1-0.
MONTRÉAL HAS A HOCKEY GAME TO
WIN NOW. DOBSON 11 ON THE SEASO.
O
LEFT.
HE RELEASES THE PUCK.
LEFT TO
EVANS GOOD LOOK.
KNUCKLE BALL.
MIKE HOFFMAN THROUGH THE CREASE
AND GALLAGHER.
AND SOROKIN GOT IT.
COULDN'T SETTLE THE PUCK DOWN
AND DRIVE.
AND OFF THE SANDWICH GETS THE
BACK HAN RESET.
PARISE TAKEN DOWN.
HIM AND SAVARD IN THEK.
SHOOTS.
PRIC STOPPED AND STILL
LOOSE AND SWUNG OUT BY MONTRÉAL
AND THE GOOD NELSON HIS SIXTH GL
VERSUS MONTRÉAL THIS SEASON. DIA
FAIRLY ENTERTAINING EVENING
IN FRONT.
AND JOEL ARMIA HAD A